So I thought the film was really entertaining,
there were a lot of big, action-packed moments,
but some really nice tender moments as well.
I have to ask - what was it like working with
not one, but THREE giant CGI animals?
Erm well one of them was really fun, because
George was played by an actor called Jason
Liles, so we had a lot to kind of react to
and he gave us a lot of emotion and so on...
And a lot of humour as well, so that was great.
But the other two were just tennis balls.
Wow.
That was it.
Tennis balls on sticks.
That's all we had to go off.
And that was tough because you have to just
use your imagination, thankfully our director,
Brad Payton, he's an amazing painter, so he
did these sketches of what the creatures were
going to look like but having them on a piece
of paper this size is not the same as seeing
them, like, ginormous.
And they're amazing on screen as well, seriously
impressive, especially when the crocodile
comes out of the water - it's a big moment.
I like the flying wolf.
I didn't think he got as much screen time
as he deserved - I'm a dog person.
Yeah that's true actually, oh yeah.
I was rooting for the wolf.
So your character is a little bit scatty,
she's really witty, and she's got a really
nice heart.
Was she quite an enjoyable character to play?
She really was, I love the fact that she's
badass as well, you know, I love the fact
that she's also really brave, she's kind of
like, okay I feel responsible for this virus
situation so I'm going to dive right in there
and put my life at risk and go and try and
save the world.
Because you know it's totally different to
me.
I'd be staying at home, hiding...
Watching it on the news?
Yeah watching it on the news, exactly.
The film is obviously a really big production,
there's a lot of stunts, did you have to undergo
any special training, or up your workouts
or switch stuff up?
So I did up my workouts, and I did sort of
work with the lady who actually prepared me
for the Bond franchise, so I worked with her
for a month before I went, but I might as
well have not bothered, to be honest because
it was not anything to do with stunts.
Oh really?
No!
It wasn't stuff that I could train for, it
was things like being strung up to the ceiling
on wires and being on a replica plane, tilted
at 90 degrees and having to swing from one
side of it to the other.
And crawl along with a wind machine blowing
in your face and, things like that really,
so I guess my workout really helped, but it
wasn't those kind of stunts like, in Bond
or what have you, it wasn't like that.
And then it was a lot of green screen stunts,
like in the helicopter and so on.
I think RAMPAGE is actually quite an inspiring
film - it kind of makes you want to get out
of bed and go and save the world...
Really?
I love that!
I haven't heard that before, I love it...
Who in your life inspires you the most?
Erm, I would say my mum inspires me the most.
I think, you know, she had me when she was
18 years old so she was very young and she
raised me on her own and erm despite, you
know, we didn't come from money at all, but
despite that my mum always taught me that
anything is possible and I could achieve anything
that I put my mind to.
That's so sweet.
And I really am just so grateful to her for
that.
As an actress you obviously do a lot of travelling,
there's a lot of long days, do you have any
wellness hacks that you absolutely swear by?
Oh my God, so many.
SO many.
I feel like waking up before 6am is really
important, that's really important because
it's good to wake up with the sun and I find
that the longer I stay in bed, the more kind
of, sleepy I am throughout the day I mean.
And then also, it means that I have, I carve
out time for myself to kind of do my routines,
which are: I like to do a bit of exercise
to get my heart rate pumping, nothing like
Dwayne's workout, not his two hours in the
gym.
And then I also meditate and then I do my
morning pages as well.
So I just kind of write whatever comes into
my head, kind of my mini diary and that's
a real great way of, things that I'm uncomfortable
with or I need to sort of dissect in my mind
I get them on the page and it really helps
me.
That's amazing, I might try that.
And I'm sure our audience would love to know
which beauty products could you absolutely
not live without?
I think the biggest one for me is cleanser.
So many of my friends go to sleep with their
makeup on.
Oh my gosh.
And I'm like, [gasp].
Cardinal sin!
Oh my gosh!
Like it's really bad.
So I would, I have to have cleanser.
I have to cleanse my face, especially after
a day like this with so much makeup on, in
front of the camera and lights all day, you
know.
Is there a specific brand that you love?
I love The Organic Pharmacy, I love Environ,
as well, I'm a big fan of Environ.
Those are my two favourites.
Amazing.
Well, thank you very much for your time.
Thank you.